bien qu en partie déchirée le message de
cette affiche de campagne est assez
clair proposé par le comité d'egerkingen
déjà à l'origine de l'initiative sur
l'interdiction des minarets approuvée en
le texte est soutenu par le parti
conservateur et nationaliste de l'union
démocratique du centre
on ya plusieurs aspects et bien
évidemment l'aspect sécuritaire on ne
peut plus parler qu'il y ait des
reliques à l'occasion des manifestations
dans ton des événements deuxième aspect
notre initiative est bien évidemment
d'interdire le micro à la burqa dans
l'espace public suisse
nous combattons ni sioniste et non pas
l'islam est une religion
ils subissent est une idéologie qui
consiste à ne pas accepter la femme qui
est pour la réputation qui est qu'ils
n'acceptent pas le lot sexualité en
suisse cette question relève du droit
cantonal de cantons interdisent déjà la
dissimulation du visage et donc le port
du voile intégral
st gall et le tessin mais les défenseurs
du texte veulent désormais l'appliquer
dans l'ensemble du territoire au niveau
fédéral un texte rejeté par certains
membres d'autres partis politiques dont
le parti socialiste suisse
le comité d'egerkingen qui est ami bien
la base de cette initiative veut faire
inscrire dans la constitution en suisse
l'interdiction du port d'un vêtement qui
n'est utilisée que par une infime
minorité de personnes en suisse à peu
près une centaine donc eu un moment
absurde de vouloir le peuple sorte
polluer notre constitution avec un
problème qui n'existe pas le conseil
fédéral et le parlement ont proposé un
contre-projet proposant que toute
personne soit tenue de montrer son
visage lors des contrôles d'identité une
contre-proposition qui seraient
immédiatement adopter en cas d'échec du
oui les suisses eux sont divisés sur la
question
personnellement je pense que alors qu'en
ce moment c'est une période particulière
parce qu'on a tous un masque mais je
pense que c'est pas possible qu'on ne
puisse pas identifier quelqu'un pour des
raisons de sécurité tout simplement je
suis à civiliser parce que je trouve que
ces femmes là on
non pas du tout le choix elles sont
obligées de porter
reporter ce match établit qu on se
trouve horrifiant mais malheureusement
si on l'interdît ces femmes là un bon
entourage une amie
isolés de la société en suisse il suffit
de cent mille signatures en faveur d'une
proposition pour que les citoyens se
prononcent dessus pour que le oui
l'emportent
il faudra la majorité des voix dans plus
des 13 des 26 cantons
selon les derniers sondages le camp du
oui reste toujours en tête mais son
avance initialement confortable a
largement fondu depuis janvier